today on the matt welsh show an nbc news
anchor says on the air that he doesn't
care about being
fair or hearing both sides i actually
agree with him on that point and i feel
much the same way and i'll explain why
also five headlines including cnn's
claim that
there is no way to determine no way at
all the sex of a baby at birth
and a school district took thomas
jefferson's name off of one of their
schools but they're having trouble
finding a new name apparently
everyone in history even very recent
history is problematic who knew plus joe
biden
butchers the spanish language while
standing in front of a very nazi-esque
flag and our daily cancellation
the woke mob finally comes for the
office we knew it was going to happen
now's the time we'll deal with that
today and much more on the matt walsh
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
now i've always been clear that i don't
care about tolerance
fairness diversity equality
well don't care is the wrong way of
putting it i should say that i actively
oppose
those things oppose them in how they're
interpreted and applied in modern
society tolerance can be fine but it
depends on
what you're tolerating there are
intolerable things many intolerable
things which should not be tolerated
there are also intolerable
people and quite a few of them walking
around
now even if you are tolerating a
tolerable thing
you don't deserve credit for it there's
no courage involved in simply
tolerating something i can tolerate
stuff from my couch i can
lay on my couch and tolerate everything
i can tolerate many things while sitting
at the beach
as long as i'm not actively opposing
something or someone
then i'm tolerating it by definition why
should i get credit for that
if i call myself a tolerant person
all i'm saying is that i don't actively
oppose very many things
another term for that is pushover see
also
weak cowardly lazy diversity can also be
fine but again it depends entirely on
the context
what sort of diversity are we talking
about and is this diversity for its own
sake
diversity for its own sake that is
diversity that's achieved
by ignoring things like merit and skill
is bad
diversity that happens as an accidental
byproduct of prioritizing merit and
skill
is fine if you for example end up with a
racially diverse
fire department because you've hired
people based on racial quotas
without respect to their ability to
actually do the job
then you've done a very bad thing and
people will probably die
because of you if you end up with a
racially diverse fire department because
you hired the best people and it just
just so happens that the best people
came in an eclectic mix of races
ethnicities
and sexual orientations then you've done
a fine thing
i mean it's fine so personally i don't
much care if the fire department is all
black or all-white or
comprised completely of transgender
polynesians
so long as they're they're all the best
applicants based on merit and skill
and will do the best job of saving the
old lady from the burning house that's
all that matters
what about equality equality under the
law is very good
though more of a theory than a reality
in this country
some people are above the law even
though they shouldn't be as we've seen
blm rioters for instance
spiritual equality that is the
recognition
that we are all humans made in the image
of god
is also good but equality in any other
sense
is bad that's because equality does
quality doesn't exist in any other
context and so it must be created
artificially
my neighbor and i both are supposed to
be equally subject to the law
we both were created by god but other
than that
we're different not equal not the same
one of us is smarter better looking more
virtuous
more talented etc and so on these
differences should be acknowledged
and they should lead to different
outcomes if they're not acknowledged and
we're forced to have the same outcome in
spite of them
then we're being stuffed into an
artificial box and our individuality and
thus our humanity is being denied
this is bad which is why equality is bad
most of the time
that brings us to fairness fairness
again has a
limited positive application there are
situations where fairness
must be emphasized such as in a
courtroom
it is unfair to make derek chovin stand
trial in minneapolis
after the city has already admitted
guilt by settling a lawsuit with george
floyd's family
that's unfair that's bad but outside of
the courtroom and a few other contexts
attempts to be fair tend to lead
ironically to even more
unfairness and this is all a very long
way of saying that i agree
partially with nbc news anchor lester
holt who
turned some heads this week when he gave
a little soliloquy on air
where he spoke out against fairness
here's what he said the unprecedented
attacks on the press in this period
i'm sure we'll fill plenty of books and
be studied in classrooms
maybe even here but i have a few early
observations i'll share about
where this moment brings us and what we
can learn
number one is i think it's become
clearer that
fairness is overrated well before you
run off and tweet that headline
let me explain a bit the idea that we
should always give
two sides equal weight and merit does
not reflect the world we find ourselves
in that the sun sets in the west is a
fact
any contrary view does not deserve our
time or attention
i know recent events assure that you
won't have to look far to find more
current and relevant examples i think
you get my point
decisions to not give unsupported
arguments equal time
are not a dereliction of journalistic
responsibility or some kind of
agenda in fact it's just the opposite
providing an open platform for
misinformation for anyone to come say
whatever they want especially when
issues
of public health and safety are at stake
can be quite dangerous
our duty is to be fair to the truth
holding those in power accountable is at
the core of our function
and responsibility we need to hear our
leaders views
their policies and reasoning it's really
important but we have to stand ready to
push back
and call out falsehoods now he sustained
plenty of criticism from the right for
saying this but i agree with the general
point he's making i don't agree with the
way that
he will apply and is applying and has
applied along with all the rest of the
left-wing media
this idea you know when he talks about
not giving equal fair time to
unsupported ridiculous ideas and claims
what he means obviously is that he
doesn't think he should give fair time
to any idea or claim that originates
from anyone on the right that's what
he's saying without saying it
what he's doing here is is giving
himself and his profession an excuse
to be dishonestly biased against
conservatives obviously that's his point
and
i'm well aware of that however the basic
idea
is correct not all ideas and thoughts
and opinions and claims
should be given equal weight not all
should be
respected or listened to you have a
right to your opinion but you don't have
a right to have your opinion taken
seriously
if it's a really stupid bad opinion i
don't have to take it seriously
i don't have to sit down and contemplate
it hmm let me think about this
there are some opinions where i can hear
it and say that's dumb that's it i'm not
even gonna
that's all i have to say about it i'm
not gonna consider it further than that
this is one of the problems i have with
conservatives who when discussing
diversity
will say well we need diversity of
thought
that's what we need well sort of but
not really i think society should be
open to and kids in school should be
exposed to a wide array
of intelligent worthwhile and defensible
ideas and opinions
but some ideas should be ignored
excluded yes
excluded because they have no worth
because they're delusional and wrong and
by treating them
with respect by being fair to them
we give the impression that there may be
some merit to these ideas when there is
no merit
for example the idea that a
five-year-old male child
may actually be a girl if he says he is
they might have a little girl trapped
inside him
so he should be dressed up like one and
referred to as one
it's one of those ideas has no merit
lester holt was not referring to this
insanity when he said that some claims
are unsupported
but this is nonetheless the best example
to prove the point
the claims made by left-wing gender
theorists are wholly worthless
without value without merit
they should not be respected we should
not give equal weight to the idea that a
boy with a penis is really a girl
we should not treat it like a claim
that's just as valid and plausible as
the claim that a
boy with a penis is a boy
we don't need diversity of thought well
we need to embrace both thoughts you
know you could have a
penis and be a boy or a girl and these
are we need the diversity of these no we
don't
kids in school should not be taught that
there are two equal and valid theories
on this subject
they should be taught the facts of
biological sex and informed that any
opposing ideas are simply false
and should be ignored of course what's
actually happening is the opposite
they're taught that boys can have
vaginas and get pregnant and that any
contrary opinion to that
is false and should be ignored the left
as lester hall just explained
is not worried about being fair to our
viewpoints
they're not willing to hear them out
even when our viewpoint
is the viewpoint of basic biological
science
now for too long the right in an effort
to seem open-minded
has responded to this intellectual
intolerance from the left by saying
but we just want all ideas to be heard
we want all opinions and viewpoints to
be given an equal hearing
it's not what i want i'll tell you right
now that is not what i want
as lester holds it himself you know it's
about the truth
except that he doesn't really care about
the truth i do what i want is the truth
i want the truth to be heard and known
and respected
i want a society based around truth
grounded in a
respect for and an acknowledgement of
and an understanding of
truth i don't want to give untruth an
equal platform
i don't want to give it equal space on
the stage
i don't want to respect it i don't
respect it
we should not be fair to lies and
deceptions and delusions
we shouldn't give them our respect we
should attack them
head on destroy them
we should be unfair to them and
intolerant of them
because again as was said the only thing
that really matters
is the truth now let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
before we get to five headlines today i
got to tell you about our good friends
over at constitutioncoach.com
now as we've been talking about many
conservatives all conservatives really
say they love the constitution they love
our liberties and freedoms
uh it's so important to defend them and
all of that but how many of us actually
stand ready to defend them how many of
us really understand these issues that
well my friends over at
constitutioncoach.com have a lot of
great programs for equipping citizens to
defend liberty by studying and living
out the constitution
i have experienced this myself at their
constitutional defense course
uh which by the way you you take over at
their um the premier firearms training
facility in the nation in nevada
and it's it's just a place that you have
to see for yourself it's experience you
have to have for yourself
you get live classes with rick green
america's constitution coach and you
also get the physical training as well
you get to join hundreds of other
patriots from across the nation for a
time of learning training and fellowship
with like-minded people the fellowship
part of this
is really important as well because
we're not alone there are other people
there are other sane people in the world
too
as uh although it may not always seem
that way whether you have whether you've
shotguns your whole life or you're a
beginner wherever you are i'm telling
you they're going to bring you to a
whole new skill level that's what they
did for me
so rick and the constitution coach team
have another class on april 25th but it
will fill up fast so visit
constitutioncoach.com today
you can watch my video there to find out
more about how you can be a part
of this one-of-a-kind training that's
constitutioncoach.com
all right um well you know the tooth
fairy saga continues by the way speaking
of uh
i just said the truth matters well
here's an example of not telling the
truth
i was saying yesterday my daughter's
very smart critical thinker
and uh which i'm proud of her for that
but um she's starting to figure the
tooth fairy thing out and and yesterday
you know i went into her room before
i left in the morning and she told me
that she'd lost her tooth
and um and she didn't tell us the night
before that she lost it because she
wanted she was running a test to see if
the tooth fairy would still come
even if she doesn't tell mom and dad and
of course tooth fairy didn't come to
coincidence
because she didn't tell us and uh and
then so
the problem is that my my wife
she she really wants to she she realizes
that it's a house of cards and if you
lose the tooth fairy in the easter bunny
then you lose santa claus and she really
wants to hang on to santa claus
for the kids for one more christmas it's
really you know she just wants one more
christmas out of it which means we got
to keep the
tooth fairy going and this is becoming
difficult because last night
my daughter i'm not making this up this
is she came up with this on her own
because she's like really trying to
figure this out and so
she came up with a plan last night where
she
um first of all she had a tooth under
the pill of course
and she uh put out some food for the
tooth fairy
i don't know that's not usually part of
the tooth fairy deal the tooth fairy
doesn't usually eat
um but so she put out so like a little
bowl of water and i think some peanuts
maybe tooth fairy eats peanuts
why not everyone likes peanuts and then
she put out some um
some baking soda around the dish
so that she could get the footprints of
the tooth fairy
really toothpaste probably probably
flying but still
and then she also said yeah she asked if
she could
use one of our phones and put up like
put a camera
there so she could capture the tooth
fairy coming in
and this was this whole plant she
concocted and my wife
told her yes let's do all that of course
i'm saying to my wife
what's your plan here with the camera
part of this how are you going to make
that
apparently there's an app for there is
an app
for this exact situation where where a
little girl is trying to figure out the
tooth fairy's real
and um anyway there's an app where you
can have like a tooth fairy come in
and show it to the kid so um
we got her she's we fooled her for
another another few months
yay us i'm so proud of us
um all right so we begin with an article
on
cnn.com about christy gnome who has
signed some executive orders dealing
with the boys in girls sports issue but
she still refuses to sign
legislation but instead she's she's
doing executive orders
the article talks about that but then it
gets to the kicker
we'll read here it says south dakota's
republican governor christie gnome
banned transgender girls and women from
competing
on women's sports teams at public high
schools and colleges via a pair of
executive orders
issued on monday of course what what she
actually banned was
boys playing in girls teams
the move came after gnome angered
conservatives by killing a bill that
would have created a similar prohibition
in a news release explaining her veto at
the time noam cited her
concern that the bill would take the
state's colleges universities out of
compliance with national rules so we
know about that she's worried that uh
the the naacp would would punish
the state of south dakota the naacp
would get really mad and and punish them
if uh if she tried to ins put this if
this ban was put in place and it applied
to colleges and she didn't want to make
the naacp mad and get punished by them
or rather the ncaa i should say she
doesn't want to just want to make them
mad get punished by them
so um she decided to do the executive
orders instead
now here we get to the kicker it says
though the two executive orders
signed by gnome do not explicitly
mention transgender athletes
they reference the supposed harms of the
participation of
quote males in women's athletics and
they put quotes around males
yeah quote-unquote males well we don't
need the quotes there that we are
talking about actual males
it says an echo of the transphobic claim
cited in
other similar legislative initiatives
that transgender women are not women
the orders also reference biological sex
a disputed term
that refers to the sex as listed on
students original birth certificates
and then here we go here it's not
possible to know a person's gender
identity at birth
and there is no consensus criteria for
assigning sex
at birth there is no consensus
criteria for assigning sex at birth
now your the first part of that sentence
is right
that there is no way to know a baby's
gender identity
because that's a made-up concept gender
identity doesn't exist
kids have to be indoctrinated into
believing in this
thing called gender identity babies
haven't been indoctrinated yet so for
them gender identity doesn't exist
that's true
the rest of it though is where we go
wildly off the rails
there's there's no consensus
think about the claim here okay think
about the claim here this is in
a news article this is not an editorial
a cnn news article saying there's no
consensus
criteria for figuring out the sex of a
child
they're not just saying that technically
we we we can't really know the sex now
that would be totally wrong also
they're claiming that there's no
consensus criteria yes there is so this
is wrong
horribly ridiculously wrong on two
levels
not only can we obviously tell the sex
of a child
most of the time all you got to do is
look between the legs um but there is
clearly a consensus criteria
every child birth that happens on earth
everywhere
and it has been this case since the
beginning of of of humanity
the criteria has been let's look at the
at the um let's look at the reproductive
organs on the child
that's that's been the criteria
that's what hospitals do i have been
been there for the the births of four
children
that's that's the way it goes
so even if you want to claim that we
can't know the sex or that
the sex of a child is fluid again all
that obviously totally wrong
you would have to you would think at
least admit that there is right now a
consensus criteria
if you want to say that that criteria
doesn't work or whatever then
then find make that case but to deny
that the criteria even exists at all
well this is what we get from the left
obviously they can they will just simply
wave
their hand and say that that truth that
this isn't happening you you thought
that that was happening
you thought that in every hospital in
the world when a baby is born they look
between the legs and the side
and and figure out what the sex is they
don't assign it by the way
there's no assignment happening the
doctor isn't looking and saying okay
this one's going to be a boy
then you just stamp the word boy on its
head that's not the way it works
but they are but that is what how
they're determining it and the left says
no that's not
that's not happening what you think
you're saying you're not seeing
oh but these are the pro-science people
remember that
these are these are the people who feel
entitled
feel like they're in a position where
they can accuse other people of being
anti-science
right um
okay number two it's from tmz it says
deshawn watson's attorney
says 18 professional he's the
quarterback for the houston texans
involved in a in a there's there's many
um
sexual assault accusations coming out
against them a lot of lawsuits and so
here's
here it says deshawn watson's attorney
says 18 professional female massage
therapists are going to bat for the qb
saying they had nothing but positive
experiences with him over the years
um rusty hardin says the women all
worked with the houston texas qb at some
point over the past five years
completing more than 130 sessions
without any sort of incident
hardin issued a statement saying these
women say they are deeply troubled by
the accusations made against deshaun and
that these claims are wholly
inconsistent
with their experiences with him and who
they believe him to be
all of them stated that deshawn never
made them feel uncomfortable or demanded
anything outside the scope of a
professional massage
okay so we've got other female massage
therapists coming out and saying
oh well he didn't sexually assault me
and that's supposed to
i guess cancel out the dozens of female
massage therapists
who said that they were sexually
assaulted now already i would think that
this
defense raised there's there's a problem
here with this defense
um the first problem obviously is well
just because he didn't sexually assault
those women doesn't mean he didn't do it
to these others
but also how many female massage
therapists does one guy
need so if you've got the 18 who are
coming out and saying he didn't assault
me and then you've got
i don't know what we're up to we're up
to like over 20 who are making claims
that he did assault them
so what is that like 40 this guy's had
40 female massage therapists in the last
five years
40 different ones it's not just he's had
40 massages
okay i understand if you're professional
athlete maybe you get a lot of massages
because of all the you know
the damage being done to your muscles
but
you need a different massage therapist
you have to keep finding different ones
40 of them
um yeah it sounds to me at a minimum
this is a guy with some issues
and then you consider 20 accusations
doesn't mean just because there are so
many accusations doesn't make it true
and again i'm the i'm the i'm you know
i'm not i'm the last guy to immediately
assume
that someone is guilty just because a
claim is being made
you know but you do have it's sometimes
it's
a just a matter of probability and
looking at the numbers
either 20 women are all lying
individually or this one guy is lying
what's more likely you add in the text
messages allegedly from him that have
been produced
actual actual evidence it's pretty rare
that you have
physical evidence presented in these
kinds of cases
it's a pretty compelling case being made
here
that this guy might be a serial sexual
abuser
and he's a major star he's a major nfl
star
and yet somehow this this you hear about
this case but it's not
getting the kind of attention that you
might expect
i wonder why that is from the daily wire
says parents at litchfield elementary
school in
arizona are infuriated over the
district's proposed equity plan that's
infused with elements of critical race
theory
the idea that america is rooted in
racism the district's transformation
equity work plan centers around the
definition of anti-racism which claims
that being not racist is insufficient
the definition suggests that parents and
educators must be actively fighting
against racism in all its forms though
what is considered racist is often
subjective
um during a school board meeting parents
slammed the board members who crafted
and supported the equity plan
one parent threatened to hold a recall
campaign against board members so we
have some of the audio here
and i always appreciate that when
there's audio of parents or students
fighting back resisting that's that's a
good thing that's
that's encouraging so let's let's play
this let me just tell you my kids
are a minority group i am hispanic
never once have they come home and said
that they felt victimized
or discriminated against because of
their race or ethnicity
[Music]
i've done a lot of research into this
transformational
equity work document as well as mr
kennedy's theory radical
theory unproven
without a lot of supporting facts and
i'm deeply concerned for my kids who are
in this district
i have had over a dozen teachers reach
out to me
frustrated and upset over what is being
thrown their way
with this transformational equity work
thanking me for speaking up for them
because they can't do it themselves
for fear of retaliation and possible
discrimination
further on the document references
reducing disciplinary action by race
reviewing library books and hiring based
on race
ethnicity gender identity faith sexual
orientation
socioeconomic class and age
you know what we have fought and battled
for equal rights in this country
this doesn't sound like equal rights it
sounds like we're going to go higher
based on
meeting a quota well you have to excuse
some of the uh the dramatic music there
underneath that's that wasn't that
wasn't our addiction but
there is the uh yeah there's parents
parents speaking out against this
insanity which
which is great um it's this is at a
minimum is what's going to be needed
parents to be aware and involved and
speaking out if you
if you feel
that you have no choice but to send your
kid to public school then you
at a minimum you got to be doing this
you have to be on top of it you have to
be aware of everything that's happening
talking your kids about it every day
when they get home
right get get the full report of what
happened what they were taught
um go to the school board meetings
you pay attention you got to do this
you have to do it or you're going to
lose your child
i mean it's that that's that's where
we're at you're going to lose your child
maybe not physically but you're going to
lose them mentally
emotionally spiritually you're going to
lose them in any every other way
the school system is going to take your
child from you
and replace your kid with someone else
turn them into something all
all the values all the ideas that you
have
instill all the the priorities and
everything that that you have instilled
in your child
the school system's job that they've
given themselves
is to take all that away and replace it
um but i can't help but but think every
time i
watch a video like this i can't help but
think that it's
a little bit like trying to empty the
ocean with a thimble
there's it's it's
there's too much the school system now
school systems across the country are so
fundamentally beholden to
you know left-wing doctrines that
there's not a lot that can be done to
change
except for as i always say get your kids
out of public school system
a little bit more school craziness a
school district in illinois
is looking to take thomas jefferson's
name off of a school but they're having
trouble now
figuring out who to replace what name to
put in place of thomas jefferson because
what they're discovering
is that everyone in history even like
recent history even recent presidents
like say barack obama
are also problematic by the left
standards today here's a report
on this from the local affiliate the
local abc affiliate let's watch that
those against the obamas as a name
choice say the former president failed
to deliver on promises
to the immigrant population tonight
waukegan's board of education heard
concerns from the public
over one of the finalists in the running
to be the new name for thomas jefferson
middle school
i want to urge the school board to drop
the names of barack and michelle obama
from consideration
i personally don't object to the name
but
i have to be aware of the concerns
the country's first black president
first lady barack and michelle obama is
one of the top three choices for the
school's new name
but one that's drawing opposition in the
area with a large latinx population
we feel that barack obama disserviced us
he denied us and he didn't stop the
deportations the way he promised
members of the area's latinx community
held a protest outside the meeting's
doors
if you're removing the name of thomas
jefferson one oppressor
the name of obama is another oppressor
and our families do not want to see that
name mauricio sanchez's father was
deported in 2015
during the obama administration it was
something very sad we had to
we couldn't even say goodbye to our dad
we just
hoped for him to be able to get out he
said his dad is still in deportation
hearings to this day and the sanchez
family says the obama name
is a reminder of their current struggles
you got to love it you really do obama's
an oppressor too you remove one
oppressor thomas jefferson can't replace
him with another barack obama
yep he's an oppressor fine
hey everybody is there's no getting
around it
nobody i mean really nobody is woke
enough now
it's it's impossible
like the only only only people who could
be woken up is someone who someone maybe
who was born
yesterday that's how recent it has to be
that we name all the schools after
infants after gender fluid infants
they're the only ones who could possibly
be woke enough
anyone who existed prior to five years
ago
is going to have done things that are
considered problematic now
or held views or said things that are
considered problematic
i mean my goodness uh barack obama was
anti-gay marriage
for most of his life he ran
in 2008 as a and as a pro-traditional
marriage
candidate which is crazy to think now
but it's true
and they didn't they haven't even
brought that up yet
he deported a few people he was against
gay marriage man
this guy was a bigot
i guess you got to take just you take
all the names down all the statues down
replace them with nothing
give all the schools numbers that's it
here's someone who might be woken up i
don't know um demi lovato
announced that she is uh pansexual
so she's a pansexual now she's kind of
been
graduating from one level to the next uh
i think at one
at one point she said she was a lesbian
or maybe bisexual but now she's now
she's pansexual
and here she is on joe rogan talking
about well
here she is talking about living her
truth um and then she gets into how
she's pansexual let's let's listen to
that
for someone like me who's always tried
to please other people by being what
they want me to be
whether it was a sexy pop star and a
leotard
or engaged to a dude like
i had to speak my truth
and tell the world hey my truth
isn't going to be what you want it to be
anymore
like i'm chopping my hair off because it
feels right to me a lot of my fans want
me to have long hair they're like they
love the long hair it's like look
how do they feel about the double
unicorns on your shirt they haven't seen
them yet
only you have them
but we'll find out and i'm eager to know
it's hilarious of people who have
expectations about your looks like how
you
how you should wear your hair yes but
that's being
a pop star yeah oh it sounds so hard
that's being a pop star
people have expectations but she's
living she had to speak her truth and
live her truth
like i said i'm kind of disappointed in
joe rogan that he that he uh
listened to her say that and didn't roll
his eyes at least i don't think he did
he wasn't on camera but
when someone uses the phrase speak my
truth or live my truth around you
and they're not being ironic or
sarcastic the only appropriate response
is to roll your eyes and say shut up
that's it
i don't care who it is that's the only
appropriate response
definitely can't nod your head and go
along with it uh huh
you're speaking the truth great that's
so brave so brave
she goes from there to talk about how
she's attracted to
she's a pansexual now and she's so fluid
she's so fluid now she says and uh and
she clarified that she's attracted to
anything
anything not even anybody anything
including maybe actual pots and pans so
in a very literal sense she's pansexual
i just love hearing these celebrities
complain about fame
i mean even putting the pansexual stuff
to the side because we know they're look
yeah the lgbt crew they're they're so
impressed
that every celebrity in existence right
now is desperate to be a part of the
club and they're coming up with anything
they can to be in there that's how
oppressed they are right
but the rest of it about uh people don't
like when you chop your hair off or
they have expectations yeah you're
famous
you have cultivated like you don't
become famous by accident most of the
time
you have to cultivate that fame you have
to try really hard
to be famous and to maintain your fame
because even demi lovato's at a level
she's really famous but
she could stop being famous if she
wanted if she went away did something
else
people would basically forget about her
and not care in a few years
or a few months so don't complain about
it
everybody has an opinion they're all
looking at you of course they are it's
what you want
this is the situation you have tried
really hard to create for yourself and
maintain
i'm not really interested in the
complaints about it
finally a little bonus thing here i got
to play this we can't we can't move on
without playing
even if you've already heard it uh jill
biden
dr jill biden esquire was giving a
speech to a group of hispanic voters
rather
latinx latinx latinx voters i should say
excuse me
and she attempted a bit of spanish
herself and it didn't go well
here it is so say it with me
si se quadre the future is ours
thank you si se padre
sounded like she was trying to say padre
but she had a speech impediment
so that's what it sounded like
but what what what okay so she was going
i think for the phrase yes we can
but she said si se puad way padre so
that's like
yes what would that be yes yes we're the
father
it become an episode of uh mori all of a
sudden
no she was going for yes we can which is
si se
puede p-u-e-d-e
i think in fact the correct
pronunciation is puede
i believe si se puede
um but that's what she gets for
attempting this should be something that
all
politicians or you know people in the
political
light should know that don't attempt to
speak a foreign language unless you know
it really really well which she
obviously doesn't and on top of that
if you're watching the video there you
saw a really curious flag in the
background
which which looks a lot like a nazi flag
it kind of has the nazi eagle the same
color scheme
um at least it it looks
much more like a nazi flag we can assume
it's not actually a nazi flag she wasn't
really at
a at a hispanic nazi rally we can assume
probably
but it looks much more like a nazi thing
it looks more nazi-esque than say
the stage at cpac you got to stretch a
lot more
to make the stage at cpac into a nazi
symbol than you did with that flag
of the eagle and the red and everything
but of course we get the controversy
over the stage but not over that flag
can you imagine if that was trump giving
a speech in front of a flag like that
we would quite literally never hear the
end of it
all right let's move on to reading
the youtube comments okay
first comment says there is zero chance
uh there is a zero percent chance matt
is not wearing skinny jeans with that
shirt
dom says i was watching this on the
daily wire but came to youtube
just for the comments on matt's shirt
michael says i've been avoiding the
comment feed for months in an effort not
to get banned but after seeing today's
shirt i no longer have fear go ahead
matt put me on my misery
stephanie says matt is trolling us we're
all focusing on the shirt but little do
we know that he's also wearing skinny
jeans
now the comment says matt's wife doesn't
mind that he's taken to wearing her
blouses
that's pretty progressive
matthew says walsh's wife was
unavailable for shirt check when he left
the house today his daughter dressed him
in this thing as payback for the tooth
fairy lies
amber says how did you fit into your
grandmother's blouse
melinda says great show good point like
always great shirt
my mom had a tablecloth like it once
then someone else says nice shirt matt
do they make it for men
okay yeah so i'm gathering from the
comments that y'all didn't like my um
my polka dot t-shirt that i wore
yesterday was that hard for you guys
was it was it difficult for you to was
it hard for you to see me in my hideous
shirt
is it was it was it so hard that you
needed to leave a thousand comments
and even to leave to message my wife
about
my wife got messages people telling on
me for the shirt that i wore
was that was that was it hard oh isn't
that isn't that too bad well
how hard do you think it is for me to be
cyber bullied
like this i came to work yesterday
feeling great okay i was feeling
confident in my in my polka dot t-shirt
i left the house i was whistling
whistling joyfully and i was saying to
myself
gee whiz i cannot wait for the gang to
see my new shirt they're gonna love it
and this is how you respond i'm not mad
i'm disappointed
and hurt frankly this is cyber bullying
i'm not i'm not going to back that i'm
not going to be intimidated by it
i'm not going to be stopped from
speaking my from wearing my truth
when my truth is polka dotted so i tell
you what here's what's gonna happen now
here's what's gonna happen now
i'm gonna wear that damn shirt once a
week for the rest of the year
just to spite you people don't put it
past me
you think you can shame me out of
wearing something
this is your fault you did this you're
gonna have to look at that
shirt every week now for the rest of the
year
your own behavior did this
every time you see it i want you to
think about
the way that you bullied me i want you
to think about the hurt that you caused
shame on you how dare you
and it's a great shirt i don't care what
you people say now a quick word from
rock auto
if you need auto parts you've basically
got two choices you can go to the auto
parts store
waste all your time driving there
walking around looking for what you want
everything's expensive there's not a
great selection they're not going to
have what you want they got to order it
online
you can do all that or you could just
pull your phone out of your pocket and
go to rockauto.com i know what i do it's
it's really a no-brainer rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
you can go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best thing of all prices at rockauto.com
are reliably low and if
you see the price at rockauto.com you
know it's not going to be better
anywhere else they're giving you the
best possible price
and it's going to be the same whether
you're a professional or
do-it-yourselfer
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts why spend twice as much to
get access to
a smaller selection of parts there's no
reason to do it
you can get an amazing selection with
rockauto.com reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need so go to
rockauto.com right now
and see all the parts available for your
car truck and remember as always to
write walsh in there how did you hear
about us box
so that they know that we sent you now i
also got to tell you about
candace of course well you've heard us
talking about candace you joined the
daily wire a few
weeks ago with the premiere of her new
talk show candace the show streams on
dailywire.com
fridays at 9 00 pm eastern 8 pm central
but you can get the audio podcast
candace on apple spotify or wherever you
listen to your podcast candace hosts a
a series of guests on the show each week
making for lively panel discussions and
insightful interviews
uh well there's been a lot of featured
guests really excited to announce that
if you watch the show
this friday there's going to be a
particularly brilliant and i have to say
a handsome guest who makes great
decisions in the kinds of shirts that he
wears
and that's me i'm a guest on the show so
you could watch for that reason or you
could just watch because it's a great
show in general
if you need some candace owens in your
podcast feed look no further head over
to apple podcast or spotify and
subscribe today and be sure to leave a
five star review
if you like what you hear now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we're canceling on top of everyone
of course who was making fun of my shirt
you're all banned from the show needless
to say
we're also canceling cat on um you've
never heard of her before and that's
part of the point she's an actress who
so far as i know
has appeared in one thing of note and
that's a christmas episode of the office
that was many years ago season three a
two-part episode called
a benihana christmas in the episode she
an asian woman plays a waitress who
michael ends up hitting on and trying to
use as a rebound
because he's depressed after just
breaking up with his girlfriend if i
remember the plot points correctly and i
probably do because i've seen all the
episodes of the office
16 times anyway kat
15 years later has decided that
it was actually racist that the role
that she was playing was racist she's
decided this a decade and a half later
here she is on tick tock explaining so
these are the things i've learned as an
actress on the benihana christmas
episode of the office
um i actually understood why bipark
actors
play racist roles you know sometimes you
gotta pay a rent
sometimes you wanna join the union
sometimes you just don't want your agent
to drop you
also this episode was before you know
wokeness
so the benny had a christmas episode is
actually one of the more popular holiday
tv episodes
um and the story line with myself and
the other asian american actress
is that we were the uglier versions of
the
actresses at the betty hanna also that
all asian people look alike
we're one big monolith and we're just
one big walking stereotype
without any personality or individuality
which is problematic oh it's problematic
that's what it is yeah i mean it's yeah
it's very problematic it's a problem
it wasn't a problem when she cashed the
check i assume she did cash it after all
wasn't a problem when she read the
script wasn't a problem at
all at any point until now but now it's
a problem
not just a problem but problematic
that's the worst kind of problem to have
now let's let's go through this okay
first of all she says
while trying to explain why she took
this allegedly racist role
that this was quote before wokeness
so now this is like the new bcad we're
gonna have
we're gonna have bwaw before wokeness
after welkness
what does that mean well she believes
and is not alone in believing that at
some point in the last like five years
society went through some kind of great
mystical awakening
and we suddenly realized that a bunch of
stuff we thought was fine and normal is
actually bad
nobody can ever explain how this
awakening occurred and why we should
consider it in awakening rather than say
mass delusion or a moral panic
there is after all plenty of precedent
for mass delusion and moral panic there
is no
precedent historically for an entire
society suddenly all at once to become
enlightened
true moral enlightenment doesn't work
that way it has never worked that way
societies
can become morally enlightened in
certain ways or
more morally enlightened in certain ways
um
but those gains are won slowly over long
periods of time
and much struggle is required to achieve
it
so if you find that
everyone woke up one day and became
hysterical about some new alleged evil
if you find that everyone is suddenly
freaking out about something that just a
minute ago seemed normal and fine
there's a much greater likelihood that
what you are experiencing is a
panic not enlightenment and panic by the
way
is pretty much the exact opposite of
enlightenment
second point the characters were
stereotypes she complains
yes well it was a comedy okay
built around stereotypes many comedies
are that's the nature of comedy what
made the office
so funny and relatable is that every
character was a distinct personality but
also a type
so you could say as you watched you know
oh yeah i know this person i have this
person in my office
michael scott was michael scott but he
also was everyone's incompetent boss
jim and pam worked so well as characters
because they felt like the type of
people
that you could meet on the street angela
was the uptight white christian woman
creed was the weird old guy stanley was
the
you know not messing around no time for
your crap black guy
all of the characters were stereotypes
intentionally but also they were
developed personalities in their own
right
that's what made the show work that was
the point of the show
and a lot of the humor in the show came
from michael having no social awareness
or self-awareness
and saying insensitive things even while
mostly trying to be
politically correct he was the butt of
the joke the joke was on him
it was about his buffoonery but even
though michael's obliviousness and
unintentional instance insensitivity was
the joke
even so it must be considered offensive
these days because the jokes often dealt
with
race sexual orientation etc i mean they
just
dealt with it that's it i wasn't really
making fun of people for the race it was
simply it was a joke that dealt with
race
it was a joke where race was a part of
the joke you aren't allowed to have
jokes that deal with those subjects
even if the jokes aren't actually saying
anything offensive about those subjects
so it was only a matter of time before
they got around to the office there have
been attempts in recent years back in
2019
the website screen rant ran an article
titled 10 episodes of the office that
aged poorly
then listing it lists the episodes that
quote aged rather poorly with their
flood of inappropriate jokes
and of course it lists all of the
funniest and best episodes
now that never really caught on in 2019
but right now
in this environment it's a different
story already there are headlines and
all the major media publications
based on with us what this unknown
actress said
and they're all declaring that the
office is now problematic
i'd say this is my prediction we have a
few weeks before nbc
starts removing some episodes attaching
offensive content disclaimers to others
this is not a very bold prediction we
know that all
comedy must eventually end up on the
burn pile
comedy involves laughing at or about
something or someone and such an
uproarious and unregulated display
cannot be allowed
by the robotic prudes who run our
culture now
one such prude a hypocritical prude as
prudes often are
is cat on and so she
along with all the people in the future
who are going to cancel this show and
get it banned as we know it's going to
happen
they are all canceled and we'll leave it
there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 cnn doesn't
believe that doctors can know a baby's
sex at birth
hollywood boycotts georgia over election
integrity measures
and a prominent newsman says fairness is
overrated check it out on the michael
knowles show